hello and welcome to see you're playing
drooling baby from Poland right yeah I
don't remember what his goopes come on
hey what's my milestone here and yeah
let's let's decline the Benoni check go
for a different kind of position I
recently played that game I wonder
what's that again so simply I'm probably
not hmm ok so age 6 so Bishop a three is
no problem here maybe it isn't so what's
there I can inform 96 there's some kind
of some some aggressive continuation
let's let's try this 96 I guess
otherwise well yeah other mu still make
much sense so 96 otherwise gotta clean
before now it's six I thought maybe d5
is a possibility take stakes should be
five but no he will actually castle hmm
okay is there some some other
continuation
CC 5g 595 hmm doesn't not sure if this
is convincing but it's interesting I'm
going to going to try it Wow oops that's
not I didn't expect that so it tries to
solve this problem in a tactical way of
course you can do it should be five
maybe or just back to a three allow them
to take who now that'sthat's kind of
debatable if this is this is a good idea
yeah okay it's interesting 94 it's
interesting
ok let's go for development yeah Bishop
cc6 BK excrete eggs can be Jake screen
shakes just looks like better here or
not is there that's a neat little trick
ok so what now I can go Queen a three
that's an interesting move I already has
got Bishop c6 Quincy five Bishop f3 yes
mmmm this would be the chance of
something okay I have to take this and
now now I am in the pin I got the pin
yeah I guess 95 try to keep as king of
the Center for the moment that's a
matter of keeping the initiative of
possible c4 and I will probably play be
fine and then castle hmm be 5v5 Queen a
three though I can take a go Queenie
seven
okay let's do this keep that pin intact
that's pretty clear but anyway and now
taking is wrong so I have to capture now
Castle CSV yeah I defended that defended
that well I guess it's good good these
got good chance is to to get his stuff
back here so I'll take here coming up
here probably castles 25 I wonder am I
wonder know is coming down hi cam
intranets a good book that's a good move
i cannot take now time morning and yeah
okay that's it's okay we've got an equal
position yet but i'm down with two
minutes so this is not great
Wow Kim have to be no I didn't play that
well now I'm not good not good the idea
i was there was badly played by me I
shouldn't be in a diverse ending him in
equal one maybe would not ever sending
yeah drawing chances are so pretty good
but it shouldn't shouldn't have come
that far
the drawing idea is to go into a single
single Luke ending trade one rook which
should be possible by activating here
ok here are the 22 seconds this is the
more serious matter
check
check check now you will win on time
position it's not another problem here I
think I'm clearly an active enough here
check shy maybe you checkmates me i
don't know i don't care anymore but Sir
it's a time issue anyway problem
probably no mate check don't see it
check check white foreheads on time yeah
okay so it's some yeah it gives good
drawing chance but okay I shouldn't
shouldn't be worse ever out of this out
of this position it's just a question if
I can somehow keep an advantage or not
maybe not I mean daddy for was a good
defensive move check yeah so here can be
five it was said that was a good defense
of course takes and this is this should
be just equal I guess 27 is strong
though that 27 is much stronger than
then other stuff mmm yeah that that sets
here black is actually a little bit more
comfortable SC 5 points of weakness I
mean I'm I have still very good drawing
chance as we have seen I think in the
game I also it was I mean I lost MP but
I still think that this has reasonable
drawing chances cheeway it when did I
action was just a channel i think the
draw I it's a draw it's a wrong way to
phrase it black can of course try with
this pawn but i think i should be able
to draw this is the correct way to to
tell it okay well but you know that's
not the end the video here i want to i
want to check something because i have
checked i shall not really
even this kind of thing that maybe I
should just play normals I mean giving
up the bishop pair voluntarily here and
then play age six is kind of yeah that
cannot be really good but I probably
played it wrong it looks very normal
actually no but maybe I should just
plain all that stuff like this is this
just just normal moves
man i should play like this it's pretty
good actually like after Bishop
therefore I have this idea and it's not
so clear how we place that when like
like this I don't really believe in this
very much computer already wants to do
this and kikyo yeah probably this is
better just normal development and not
not especially three stops I yeah that's
actually strong I was more expecting
something like this but this is so this
is a strong defense okay well thanks for
watching